welcome to this video playing Grand
Master our st from Georgia yeah Georgia
and let's check if the surname in down
nope okay so we get the bishop a phone
line of the Queens gambit again recent
games are I prefer to to play him my
more regular repertoire I had a really
bad run just before and I wanted to have
some someone yeah some security some men
away to play I'm opening slide a little
bit better this is ages since i since i
looked at this before Luke see one yeah
let's see what happens yeah black has
the isolated deep on but he's got active
pieces there's a pond b6 bishop on age
five when a pin so it's not them
it's not a problem for black this
isolated pawn okay this is a well known
position type with e 4g for what white
is doing is expanding in the center and
the ideal thing would be to be able to
play Knight d2 and F for getting them
them they are the biggest possible space
advantage mm-hmm okay so f6 me I could
give the check here but it's not really
leading to much okay
I'm planning to play at four so 95 I'm
going to go and form only hope that term
I'm not sure this this is great for me
not sure at all
he's got his country rock coming to see
three or queen
okay I need to take him first then
player for the questions the art exactly
this is exactly the point but how is
this position mmhmm yeah takes with
check should be too
Bishop f2 I mean takes tags
hmm yeah I don't know I don't know this
end came
it's probably Jewish check
I have an active King so I don't think
I'm I can be enough Jack big trouble
rook da died o king III Roxy 1 i'm not
sure about rook c8 to be honest this
could be a problem goddess I don't think
of this this problem now I'm covering
everything in playbooks he wants it to
him yes of course he can he can get he
can get to to this pawn but I'm I have
fun something to check on the queenside
as well
group Here I am
yeah yeah they're both they're both week
ok just this one is better
check
yeah better better better not really ok
check
yes probably just lost sent game
f5 is simple and good
yeah I don't know why it's not playing
at five I'm also threatening to take on
f6 so and taking 1g5 is just just
ridiculous why would you play with the
triple porn yeah of course so I can also
i don't have any possibility to to cover
it
yeah it's just it just lost this end
game and very important is that he's got
in fact he's got really those 2g pawns
this is so really important
check
of course no it's protecting no he's
protecting g7 okay i can resign fight
resigns yeah i miss just the endgame my
father would would comfortably hold it
maybe I can f5 is a drone him f5 f5 yes
yeah it makes a lot of sense like it's
not threatening much he cannot he
doesn't threaten to take before i take c
to me and I five just clarifies the
kingside that's very easy drawn yeah
I'll call so all this is not not too
thrilling I probably am committed some
mistake in maybe night h4 wasn't so
great I don't know or something else
here I don't know very complicated
position in general this kind of
structures are considered to be quite
okay for white um I mean quite okay as
an understatement usual you think that
one is better but um I probably did
something wrong here
yeah well this end game was a draw so
it's not too fatal but yeah hard to tell
with this limited term time I have for
the brief analysis um what went wrong
though alright thanks for watching